BUT WE ARE SEEING A LOT OF IT
AROUND THIS CITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
THE PEOPLE OF KYIV ARE
MOBILIZING.
ACROSS THE CAPITAL, VOLUNTEERS
ARE POURING IN, BUILDING UP THE
CITY'S DEFENSES WITH WHATEVER
THEY CAN.
WOMEN BRINGING EMPTY BOTTLES TO
BE MADE INTO MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
THE LEADERS OF IN MILITIA SAY
UKRAINE WILL WIN THIS WAR,
EMBOLDENED BY RECENT SUCCESSFUL
OPERATIONS TO REPEL RUSSIAN
FORCES.
ONE SHOWS US HIS PASSPORT.
I AM ORIGINALLY RUSSIAN, HE
SAYS.
BUT NO RUSSIAN BOOTS WILL STAND
HERE.
DO YOU HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN?
>> PUTIN [ BLEEP ].
>> Reporter: IT IS A POPULAR
SENTIMENT ON THE STREETS.
THIS MAN'S SIGN IS TOO VULGAR IT
TRANSLATE.
ANOTHER BILLBOARD WARNS INVADING
FORCES.
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS LEAVE, HOW WILL
YOU LOOK YOUR CHILDREN IN THE
EYE?
UKRAINE HAS BORNE THE BRUTALITY
OF THIS INVASION WITH PATIENT
GRIT AND DETERMINATION.
OUTSIDE EVERY SUPERMARKET THERE
ARE LONG LINES AND SCARCE
SUPPLIES.
BUT NO ONE IS COMPLAINING.
IT IS AMAZING TO SEE THE
OPTIMISM OF PEOPLE HERE, THEY
HAVE BEEN WAITING IN THIS LINE
FOR ABOUT 40 MINUTES TO GET INTO
THE SUPERMARKET.
BUT STILL THEY'RE SAYING
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE OKAY.
YOU CAN FEEL A GROWING
CONFIDENCE AMONG PEOPLE THAT
THEY DO HAVE A CHANCE TO DEFEAT
RUSSIA.
IN AN EASTERN SUBURB OF THE
CITY, THIS FRONT YARD HAS TURNED
INTO A STAGING AREA.
YOU CAN SEE THEY'RE COLLECTING
THINGS TO DONATE TO PEOPLE,
SLEEPING BAGS, SLEEPING MATS,
PICKLES, FOODS.
SHE IS A GRANDMOTHER AND A
RETIRED ECONOMIST.
NOW SHE SPENDS HER DAYS
PREPARING FOR BATTLE.
OKAY.
THIS IS WHERE THEY MAKE THE
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS?
SHE SAID SHE'S GOING TO SHOW US
THEM NOW.
THESE ARE THE ONLY WEAPONS SHE
HAS, BUT SHE SAYS SHE'S READY TO
FIGHT.
LET THOSE RUSSIAN -- COME HERE,
SHE SAYS.
WE'RE READY TO GREET THEM.
HOW DID YOU LEARN HOW TO MAKE
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS?
GOOGLE HELPED, SHE TELLS ME.
YOU GOOGLED IT?
OF COURSE, SHE SAYS.
IF RUSSIAN FORCES PUSH INTO THE
CAPITAL HERE IN KYIV, WHAT WILL
YOU DO?
WE WILL BEAT THEM.
THEY WON'T COME, SHE TELLS US.
I BELIEVE IN OUR UKRAINE.
I BELIEVE IN UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
MOMENTS LATER, SHE IS OFF.
RUSS